[Music]
doo-doo-doo-doo
my name is Kelly Bundy and welcome to
the endgame class today I wanted to come
to kind of continue my topic from the
road to 2000 once again really the only
chess tournament going on right now is
this Magnus Carlsen Invitational that
has some of the world's elite chess
players squaring off online in some
rapid chess and as luck would have it
thankfully they played some interesting
and the games and that's what I wanted
to take a look at here today now looking
at my screen here I have a game between
Yong Nepal mushy and Fabiano Cara wanna
of course two players in the candidates
this year perhaps getting some more
practice before this latter half of the
candidates resumes now as you may have
read in the title this is an endgame
class which means I don't care about any
of this garbage I don't know what this
is this looks like chess some opening oh
and it looks like a middle game now
we're getting closer some pieces are
coming off the board and wait what's
this wait a second more more trades more
trades wait is it an endgame yet I don't
know wait okay now it's an endgame now
it is an endgame so this is the endgame
I wanted to start off with it's a little
bit of an imbalance endgame in more ways
than one
so taking a look here at this position
obviously you can see who ended up
winning the game but who do you think is
better to start with in this endgame and
why of course we just saw the moves rook
g1 from Fabiano care wanna forcing more
or less this Queen for two rooks
imbalance so in this case what's better
the queen or the two rooks and why
I believe it sits around game in 20 with
a little bit of a delay
I don't recall the the exact time
control but somewhere around there its
its rapid chess and it's 15 plus time
I'm being told I trust Akash in the chat
I trust him
well you guys are thinking Peter has a
question for me
cheap degrading in 1550 in eighth grade
and then it looks like he lost interest
in chess but he's interested again three
years later
what's your peak rating potential really
just depends on people if you're
interested in chess again everybody
loves to improve but the best way to do
that is is to really just keep playing
chess keep getting familiar with the
game and I mean obviously I won't say
this guy's the limit cuz you probably
won't be a super grandmaster but you can
take the game really really far no
matter when when you start so people are
suggesting specific moves some people
are saying the the queen is better here
because the king is vulnerable if y can
can coordinate the rooks and get them to
the seventh then they would be better
the queen is better because white
doesn't have the coordination yet Queen
since since the knight is a bit less
safe okay our Kirsch is taking back his
time control comment I have no idea what
the time control is we're back to it to
confusion so in this case the chat is
actually pretty correct here the queen
is going to be the better piece in this
endgame largely because this White King
lacked shelter so if you ever find
yourself in a situation well I guess in
this case her g1 is more or less force
in a situation where you have the
opportunity to go in for an endgame with
a queen against two rooks
the key piece is to look at are really
gonna be the Kings in this case the
black King is really safe whereas the
White King lacks shelter and so there's
one main reason why black is simply
winning in this endgame on top of that
the chat was also mentioning that the
rooks lack coordination that is the
other key feature of Queen versus double
Brook and games
if the rooks can work together to either
defend a lot of squares or attack a lot
of squares then of course you know the
rooks are going to be better than the
Queen two pieces kind of just outrank
one in this case though the rooks don't
really seem to be coordinated and it's
difficult to coordinate the rooks with
this Bishop taking away so many squares
in the game Fabiano played the move
Queen e1 check the King has two
run to h2 and now simply queen f1 is a
really annoying move just to lock this
king kind of imprison on this h2 square
and hit this rook as well now the move
rook to see theory was played and I
wanted to ask you here to try and come
up with a plan to really kill yon
Napoleon is she here try and come up
with a very distinct plan to kind of end
this game for the first endgame of
tonight I really gave you a good one cuz
you're just totally winning out of the
gate it's all about finding out how to
put the final nail in the coffin though
I've been told it's a confirmed 15 plus
10 for the time control excellent
[Music]
well safer is kind of a relative term
yawn in in the game the king actually
did not make it to h3 but even on h3
it's going to come under a lot of
threats at least one wreck is gonna have
to be dedicated to this first ring to
stop any Queen h1 mating threats and
it's it's not gonna be easy I'm not
gonna be easy yes the rooks are doing an
excellent job of social distancing but
that's not all
not always what you want when fighting a
war you want pieces working together so
I mean Bishop e3 is is a fine move but
probably the move rook g2 is is okay
well actually hold on I found the
problem
there should be three would be great but
I can take it so hi I'm a doc gamer does
in fact actually have the correct plan
here it's often the case and end games
like these where one king is weak but
one side kind of just lacks the material
to get at the king so in this case it'd
be great if our bishop could contribute
to the attack and maybe we could do some
like crazy maneuver trying to get it to
like b6 or something to help support the
attack on g1 but in this case it's much
better to bring in more attackers now I
hear you screaming at home but these are
the only two pieces of course the pawns
can be useful attackers as well and it's
actually a really common plan and end
games like this where one side does have
the Queen against the two rooks to use
the pawns both as kind of levers to open
up more diagonals more files and as
attackers themselves to use the pawns
themselves to control squares around the
King to make their own threats so the
plan that gamer suggested here is of
course Bishop g5 as the first move rook
g2 was played by white in the game and
now you simply play at h5 as Fabiano did
in the game and you are really starting
to break down the structure around the
black the black or the what and the
White King sorry although I will say I
messed up my order but Fabi included the
move rook Queen e1 which attacks this
rook or d3 and then Queen b1
see three this doesn't really change the
position at all and then he continued
with this nice move h5g takes h5 was
White's choice to try and keep the
shelter around his King but simply G
takes h5 now white threw in 92 hitting
the Queen of course black isn't
interested in trading off this bishop
for this night this bishop is going to
be used to help get at the white king so
Queen D 1 was fabi's choice and now
after rook d3 Bobby takes the time to
play King f8 stepping off of this file
and after rook F 2 I'm sure you guys can
find the winning move here if you at
home want to take a second to do it
you're welcome to try go ahead pause the
video I'm just gonna show it
the move is of course h4 you just break
down the last defender in front of the
white king adding in another attacker
with this H pawn and white is simply
lost G a G takes h4 was played Bishop
takes h4 rook g2 and now simply king e7
and this King has a total total total
lack of shelter Ric b3 was played in the
game and you really see these these
rooks still not working together Queen
e1 comes on the board here Knight c4 is
White's try and then I'll allow you guys
at home
one more move to try and find for
yourselves white or black to move and
pretty much either ensure to ensure
checkmate or win significant material so
ensure checkmate or win significant
material see if you can do it
um so Gerard is asking about the d2
square I believe that most moments the
bishop was guarding the d2 Square and
most moments
what was Queenie one threatening well it
was threatening this move which I'm a
dogs gamer again has the correct answer
along with Scott Mulligan and that move
is Bishop g5 you bring the bishop to f4
and this is the the checkmating pattern
that's Bobby found in the game yon kind
of relented and captured this free
Bishop but of course now there is Queen
h4 check in this rook gets picked up and
from here now it is in fact just a very
serious material edge for Fabi and he
won this game pretty easily the night in
the rook aren't nearly good enough to
stop the Queen in this case queen c1 was
played the knight is attacked 93 was
tried Queen d2 as a check King g3 and
now King e6 9 of 5 was played Queen d1
hits the rook and after some more
maneuvering Queen g1 check rook g2 Queen
e1 this Queen just gets after this white
king here and in fact checkmate sit on
e6 and this is really the style you need
to follow when playing with the Queen
you just go after that King if you can
kill that King you win the game and
that's really where the Queen excels
where the rooks do not the Queen is a
great attacker especially in tandem with
other pieces on the board if you can
break up the shelter around the
opponent's king that's when the Queen is
better than the two rooks in the endgame
so it's an important note to keep in
mind and a really cool game by Bobby
here showing how the Queen is a very
very dominant piece okay with the easy
one out of the way let's move on to some
more end games and now I wanted to look
at one that is technically a very very
equal endgame but because one player was
Magnus Carlsen somebody ended up winning
the game so why don't we take a look and
see how this one went of course it was
Magnus against akaru nobody cares about
this stage of the game what we're
interested in here is the endgame so in
this case white played a pretty
interesting opening where he went for c5
early early on gaining some extra space
but black play it pretty solidly
throughout the game and really is doing
just totally fine here
in the game after night a for the
Cardinal Morel went for Queen a6 taking
off the last major pieces Queen takes a
six-night takes a6 and now after 93 we
have the simple two nights end game so
if you're magnus carlsen here how do you
think you should go about even trying to
to win this game how can you even
attempt to to win a game that looks like
this I'm willing to take some ideas in
the chats
how can you try to win a game like this
it's tough it's honestly tough it's
especially tough because if you ask a
computer it's gonna say you just don't
win that's that's how you win this game
you don't cuz it's a draw and computers
only know how to speak the technical
truths about chess rather than the
practical considerations
so jana has a very interesting
suggestion his suggestion is to play b5
which certainly create some balances
just not so sure they're they're
favorable
so the common thread here seems to be
people want to play well sorry it's
blacks Flaxman black played f6 in the
game trying to keep an eye on the e5
square but people want to try things
like b5 and in c6 probably their their
opinion would change after the move f6
cuz now this this pawn is is simply
going to hang but b5 isn't a bad idea at
all trying to create a passed pawn is a
classic way to to try to win the game
but f6 does kind of put a damper on
those plans someone else I believe said
try and target c6 which is a good idea
it's a little bit difficult to achieve
someone else said a vague principle
known as the principle of two weaknesses
you should try and create two weaknesses
somewhere on the board to win the game
and that's actually kind of exactly
right
in this case we do have sort of a
weakness on c6 it's it's tough to get
out right now but you know moves like B
takes or C takes b6 + b5 or are always
going to be threats and so we
essentially have threats on the Queen
side of the board so black has to divert
pieces to this side of the board a
little bit now on the Kings side this is
really where things aren't yet
determined and this is where Magnus
started he started by taking space on
the Kings side and by taking space you
do actually take on a little bit of risk
of course the farther up you push your
pawns the weaker that can become the
more susceptible to attack they can
become but once you take that extra
space if you managed to hold on to it
then your pawns are much closer to being
very very relevant to creating more
threats of course simply because they're
closer to queening and so this is how
Magnus Carlton Carlson attempted to win
this game he starts with the move Knight
d2 black activates the King with King f7
and now the move f4 comes on the board
Magnus isn't really afraid to leave this
pawn behind he's gonna expand with moves
like g4 and he's going to take as much
space as he possibly can on this side of
the board to try and shut the black
pieces a little bit thin in the game
night c7 was Takara Nakamura's
move once again just trying to get his
pieces back into the game and now Magnus
took the time to activate his King King
up to 95 King f3 was played and now this
Knight comes in to c3 Magnus isn't
really deterred by this Knight though
this Knight can't really get at anything
important and it's not gonna create
serious threats all by itself so as
stated Magnus tries to take as much
space as he can with g4 and now perhaps
it doesn't change the evaluation of the
position at all but what it does do is
give his opponent some more practical
issues to figure out and that's how end
games like these at the top level are
won and lost it's not always about the
objective evaluation
it's about whose position is easier to
play which position can create problems
for the opponent to have to solve and
Magnus is simply trying to give his
opponent problems by taking this extra
space on the Kings side in the game car
Nakamura went for g5 if you try and keep
the pawn structure a little bit more
symmetrical with the move like eath our
f5 rather while you're running into
things like see takes b6 and 95 already
just kind of winning upon so it's a
little bit tough already for Cara
Nakamura in this position that's why g5
came on the board
and now after g5 Magnus in fact goes for
this move f5 here perhaps psychology
starts to play a little bit of a role if
you're a black in this position you're
pretty sure you're the one trying to
defend trying to get a draw and so black
probably wasn't looking for too many
opportunities here to try and take the
advantage if her car had played them
with a takes f5 it's kind of a classic
case of Magnus perhaps over pushing with
this pawn being a little bit too far
advanced in becoming weakness itself so
black to move here and solidify you know
kind of an advantage likely the position
is still a draw but the black to move
and really take the upper hand in this
endgame well let you at home try and
find it here I'll give you a hint it's
not some tactical line it's it's in fact
quite simple
and a quick question if black ever takes
Whitby takes see there are a couple ways
white could actually take back in this
case both are are pretty relevant here
it depends on the position but in
general it does allow white to create
more imbalances with D takes e5 this
would be the practical way to to play
for more than a draw playing D takes e5
with ideas of pushing b5 later but no
reason really to be even allowed this
decision for white right now the b-pawn
is okay so someone in the chat has the
correct answer his name is in a very
foreign language that I don't know how
to read the movies b5 here and this is
the move for black because it takes away
White's threats on the queenside
and frees up the Knights to to move a
little bit more freely now if white
isn't careful placed for example some
kind of nonchalant move let's say I
don't know how to even play a nonchalant
move like King g4 here
well now the move Knight be eight is
actually gonna come on the board and if
white passes again Knight a6 is gonna
come on the board and next thing you
know net a2 is gonna come on the board
and you're gonna have some pretty
serious issues on that side of the
boards move b5 would have been the
problem however in the game black went
for this move e5 instead trying it to
play in the center a little bit and now
Magnus simply plays Knight c1 stepping
out of this efore Fork and not really
taking on e5 when black would in fact be
perhaps getting the upper hand of this
trade here you get a protected passed
pawn but blacks pieces get really really
active so Knight see one instead now if
you try the move b5 it doesn't really
come with quite the same effect here
because white is simply a little bit
faster at attacking this c6 pawn so in
the game after Knight c1 e for check was
played king f2 and black brought this
King over to e7 now how do you want to
organize your pieces if you are magnus
carlsen here how can you go about
continuing to make annoying threats for
your opponent what can you do
I've been told the very foreign language
is Greek in the chat
so where do you want to stick the pieces
to give Hikaru Nakamura some trouble
here remember that principle of -
weakness this idea stretching the black
pieces then creating threats on both
sides of the board
King g3 and h4 not quite not quite in
this case h4 doesn't really get you
anything let's say black just passes
even if you play h4 here and pass H
takes G v h6 g5 at very least for black
black may have had better in that
sequence but you don't really change
anything you just trade trade ponts with
this idea
so okay I'm getting some vague one or
both specific one move responses here
from the chat let me phrase it a
different way which square do you want
your first night on which square do you
want your second night on in which
square do you want the King on and which
order do you kind of want to do these
things in so Michael has a plan for this
night Michael wants to bring this night
to f1 and then 2 G 3 and then H 5 what
are we doing with this other night I
quite like this plan for night number
one here this night on D 2 but what are
we doing with night number 2
tonight on c1 where does this guy go and
yet the B 3 square has been suggested
and I think this is really the best
square that this Knight can hope for it
is creating some threats on the Queen
side if black ever dares to play b5 then
I can step into a 5 in one turn and
attack this c6 pawn so that's where I
want my two knights and as for the King
where are we putting the king d2 has
been suggested and I think that's that's
a perfectly fine square for this King
you want it centralized so it can impact
this Queen side which seems a little bit
more fluid right now as well as come
back to the Kings side if need be or
even up the board and some crazy crazy
line that might never happen so Magnus
does exactly that he wants threats on
both sides of the board so he once a
night to be able to come here and he
wants the knight to be able to come here
threats on both sides to stretch the
black pieces then so Knight f1 was
played it's a perfectly good move
no Knight a 4 from akaru now I should
say the evaluation in the position has
not changed it's still a dead dead draw
but Magnus is still somehow pressing
just by giving his opponent the
opportunity to slip up creating problems
for his opponent now King e2 came on the
board bringing the King into the center
Knight B - from Hikaru he's shuffling a
little bit we have king d2 and now
Knight sea floor check karu plants the
knight on the square trying to create
threats against III King c3 was played
and now Nyepi 8 comes on the board from
Karim and now Knight b3 gets played and
black to move here and secure the draw
pretty much just totally secure the
drought black to move see if you can
find how akaru could have more or less
ended this game
now I say more or less just to end up
the game magnets of course still
probably would have would have kept
pressing what I've kept trying as Magnus
does I'm too impatient with the chat
delay to catch up on this one I'm sure
people have it the idea I'm talking
about is actually just going to be the
move
b5 b5 really does lock down the position
a little bit more by not allowing white
to have this idea it with C takes b6 and
yeah the chat is caught up and they also
suggest b5 by not allowing C takes b6
you you really limit White's
opportunities here you can still play
moves like 95 but now the move King d7
is going to be blacks response and this
Knight has a little bit of freedom to
defend the weakness on the King side
while the King defends the weakness on
the Queen's side I'll apply continue for
example you can't play Knight g3 because
of this e3 pawn so what do you really do
maybe you try to bring the knight over
but now net a6 sorry the King over but
net then Knight a 6 if you draw this
Queen back while still Knight a 6 is
going to come and where are you going
with this night if you go this way the
King will step over and there's just no
real way for white to break through he
has too many weaknesses of his own to go
pawn hunting like this so b5 would have
been the move for Carver Nakamura
instead Knight a 6 was played and it is
still a dead draw but now Magnus takes
on b6 we see Knight takes b6 and now
Knight a5 and things are just a little
bit more fluid here this pawn of course
is under pressure so King d7 was played
but now Knight g3 and we see weakness
number 1 and weakness number 2 Magnus is
starting starting to converge starting
to create these problems once again King
c7 was Carter's choice clearing off this
d7 square known ith 597 looks like
everything's under control for the
moment but now it's simply Knight b3 and
he's Magnus once again is just bringing
this piece around
to help somewhere else on the board and
now was finally the mistake for Hikaru
Nakamura so I want to ask you to find
the draw for black here instead I will
ask you to try and find the win for
white after the move King d8 how does
white win the game one slip up from the
karo was all it takes and now black is
simply busted black is busted
wait to move and win the game
letting the chat catch up on this one
because this one's important this one is
critical as they say so I'm a Doc's
gamer does in fact have the correct
first move correct first move of course
is the move Knight to c5 not not a a5
not a 985 simply kind of repeats I think
after Kings Knight or King c7 I remember
this night just actually came from a
came from a5 we came back and black
played King d8 the move Knight c5 is in
fact the idea and the problem for black
now is if you dare to take this night
off the board we're gonna play B take c5
not D takes e5 and the king is starting
to invade this Knight can no longer
really get to the e3 Square unless it
you know goes really journeying which is
just never gonna happen and this King is
quite close to invading on the Queen
side and because this King is kind of
locked defending against the other King
here that's what gives this Knight a
little bit more freedom to come around
and wreak some havoc on these pawns he's
got three weaknesses to attack it's not
gonna be so easy for the Black Knight to
defend all of them and so Magnus would
simply be winning if Knight takes e5 in
the game he played an IP eight which is
a perfectly fine move
but now the really killer move from
Magnus Carlsen is this move b5 of course
these end games are all about getting
your King into the game and B five gives
Magnus Carlsen the path into the game
that he needed C takes b5 played in the
game and now King b4 and this is this is
the reason why Magnus ends up winning
this game he used this extra space to
get his King active to use the
weaknesses on opposite sides of the
board to stretch the black pieces a
little bit thin and then he struck when
the iron was hot
played b5 got his King in the game
knight c6 check King takes B 597 check
King a6 this King has invaded now rather
than kind of sit back and allow you know
death to come for him
hikaru tried trading off one pair of
nights
Magnus actually took on a seven rather
than taking on five and perhaps this was
a little bit of a mistake here taking on
c5 would have been a much much much
clearer win with this past pawn the move
d4 is really not a threat
this knight can very easily come back to
catch the e pawn but King takes a seven
instead and now the game kind of
continues the move Knight d3 could have
been tried for karu giving up this f6
pawn instead going for a really crazy
Knight f4 sacrifice to get to h3
when this move would actually end up
losing the game not I'm sorry not too
edgy takes up 4 but instead to e3 when
the knight cannot catch the pawn but you
know that that was a little bit wild and
you know white is still holding a
comfortable advantage here just by by
bringing the King over I believe so that
was kind of missed but that's one of
those types of tactics that's just
really kind of impossible to find
especially in a rapid game maybe he
comes up with this in a classical game
but I'd be very very impressed the
principle of the endgame that I want you
to walk away with is getting the King
active using this principle of two
weaknesses so in the game
Carter simply plays the move Knight 9b3
and now after King b6 King d7 this move
Knight takes f6 Jack comes on the board
and all of the black pawns kind of
collapse a Carter tried this Knight
sacrifice but after a takes d4 resigned
when he realized that after the move III
the white knight is in fact catching up
to this pawn taking advantage of the
Kings placement move Knight a 6 or
Knight a 6 would both win when after E -
there is 95 check in 93 stopping this
pawn and winning the game so that is how
magnus carlsen ended up winning it in
this end game which likely should have
been a draw by all rights objectively
was a draw but practically Magnus
Carlsen found chances and executed when
his opponent finally slipped up so the
key points I want you to take away from
this endgame
our first of all way back near the start
of the endgame here we see Magnus go for
this idea with f/4g 4 + f5 taking extra
space in the endgame is a really great
way to create more threats on the other
side of the board
so threats on both sides of the board
any dead so by taking extra space from
there he kind of separated his pieces a
little bit sending one night to attack
on the Kings side the other two attack
on the Queen side and the King to kind
of float around defend some weaknesses
and step into the Queen side if
necessary so creating threats on both
sides of the board and then from there
the really nice finish by Magnus was
really this idea of 95 with be fived
follow the final way to break through
into the position is by giving your King
an avenue to invade and once the King
invaded White was was simply winning
alright so that's all I have for that
game on to the third end game of the
night this is one between Maxima of a
Shilla Grove and Anish Geary and their
match in the Invitational
once again I don't care about the
opening I don't care about the middle
game I don't care about all these
tactics all I care about is when we
finally arrive at the end game which we
are officially in here so this is what
I'm calling the start of the very
interesting end game played between MVL
and Anisha Geary now once again you
could probably see the result on your
screen but I want to ask you who is
better here and and why and once you say
white because of course you're going to
say white is better
I want I want to understand how with
white do you really get this advantage
how do you get this advantage why do I
only show Gary's games when he's losing
he just loses in interesting ways it's
it's kind of a compliment actually to be
able to you know play chess so well that
your opponents have to play pretty
brilliant games too
to win
so why is white better here
thank you for watching King Lear
why is--why better in this endgame
white can make a passed pawn easily but
the bishops are of opposite colors so
that is why white is better and you're
saying black has good drawing chances
because these bishops are on opposite
colors however as we'll see in the game
it actually ends up being quite
difficult for black so it is true why it
is better here because he can easily
make a passed pawn so I want to ask you
guys after the moves rip d8 in Bishop a4
move rook d5 was played and I guess you
can kind of find this move because it's
forced but of course the best move for
white here is to create a passed pawn
with the movie 6 this is the move that
gives white a very significant advantage
with east 6 black more or less has to
take this pawn and after Rick takes east
6 this F pawn is now a passed pawn
whereas black has to work quite hard to
create a passed pawn on the Queen side
of the board whereas white already has
this pawn on f2 now I want to mention if
this pawn and let's say after a key 5 if
this phone were on h2 then this game
would absolutely just be a dead draw
but this pawn is on f2 making it a
passed pawn and giving white quite
significant chances now if you find
yourself in an endgame of bishops of
opposite colors if there are rooks on
the board your winning chances are
greatly greatly greatly increased having
the rooks on the board allows you to
make extra threats allows you to make
threats against the King and allows you
to attack squares of both colors for one
so of course white does not trade the
rooks here white wants to keep the
winning chances alive and so white plays
the move rook d6 now Bishop c5 came on
the board for black rook d2
by a white guarding the second rank for
a moment I'm preparing to organize the
pieces King g7 and now I want to ask you
what's the the winning plan here for
white how do you give your opponent
problems that are difficult to solve in
this position it's a little bit easier
to come up with a winning plan and in
this position then the last position
because white does actually have an
advantage
whereas in the previous position I would
argue it's it's just dead equal that
equal also higher rating that is another
advantage that is often overlooked in
chess
so what's the winning plan here for
white alright well the chat is answering
I'm just gonna give you guys the answer
because they won't hear me for another
30 seconds okay heart Harshal Kanna does
in fact have the winning plan in the
immortal words of the Aster Sara Juan
push him baby alright you gotta push
them so this is how white is going to
make threats for black in this position
simply pushing this F pawn up the board
in tandem with the Jeep on in order to
give black serious problems if black
can't stop these pawns well then he's
gonna lose the game so for black
obviously the goal should be to get
active counter play in order to prevent
these pawns now with bishops of opposite
colors let's say for example somehow the
the rooks got trade let's say why it was
was a little bit worse at chess than MDL
and the rooks got traded well if that
happens then black can really kind of
just take a passive approach here by
guarding the dark squares I move like h6
I move like Bishop e7 and guess what
you're never gonna be able to play the
move g5 and as such you're never gonna
be able to play the move f6 and that's
kind of just a perfectly easy draw for
for black to set up here passively
defending blockading the pawns
however with rooks on the board it is
not nearly so simple with rooks on the
board if you try to go for something
similar let's let's say you know King g2
King here let's say white passes for a
few turns allowing you to get this set
up
b3 it's true that you can kind of try
and set up a fortress here where you are
you know defending all your stuff you
know and trying to create a strong point
on this g5 Square
you're still gonna run into problems
with moves like at fort now this trick
has to move out of the way and already
with this rook in the game you'll see
that that these pieces get shaken loose
quite easily especially with the rook
and Bishop it's enough material to make
significant threats against the king so
with these rooks on the board this is
why white has extra winning chances this
of type of blockade simply isn't going
to be enough for black which means black
has to be a little bit more creative has
to go for some activity rather than
passive blockading I know I took a while
to get to the point there but hopefully
that makes some sense
so b6 Bishop b3 for white this was
actually the game position now black
does play h6 it's still useful to try
and guard the bg5 square it's just not
the only thing you can do now f4 comes
on the board very natural play from
white hitting this rook rook e3 rook d7
check murky seven rook d8 and now a
black starts kind of wasting some time
here and like I said passive defense is
not really going to be enough for black
he starts playing moves like Bishop b4
which I mean it's it's a fine move but
it's not really not really what we want
here you know and we'll see in the game
this Bishop comes to e1 and then back to
c3 and then back to f6 kind of just
wasting wasting a ton of time so instead
of that I'd like you guys at home to
come up with an active plan for black to
get closer to attaining a draw you want
to find something active to do so let's
see if you can at home come up with an
active way to give white some some speed
bumps on his pathway to pushing these
pawns
what can you do with black to just
harass white a little bit slow down
these pawns on the kingside
so Brian says at least try something on
the queenside and that's not a bad idea
at all so how should you go about trying
things on the queenside well it turns
out the the best way to do it is
actually just to leave this pawn on b6
and start pushing this guy up the board
this is one way to kind of give white
some some real problems so the best line
I could come up with also involves
getting this rook active this was kind
of the first thing I wanted to do when I
saw this position yes having the rook on
the e-file is important because we need
to guard against these checks but having
this rook on a slightly more active
Square it can also come in handy now for
example let's say white plays the move I
move like your associate or something
now I wanted to get the Queen side pawns
rolling as Brian had suggested here you
want to try and create some threats on
the other side of the board make it so
that white can't just totally commit all
of his pieces to the Kings side now King
edge three would be a very natural move
for white of course a four is slightly a
threat here with the idea of rookie to
check so King h3 for example and now why
not play a move like rook efore rather I
was gonna say Bishop e7 but I think
Ricky four is a bit better once again
just actively giving white problems in
his quest to push these pawns of course
white doesn't really want to play the
move f5 this does allow black to set up
a more permanent blockade with sticking
this King someplace annoying like a like
g5 for example so g4 then would also be
tough due to Rick takes F force so
rookie four momentarily giving white
some problems it's like King g4 gets
played you know why it still comes up
the board well now these moves like a
four are already really getting it quite
close to just an absolute draw if this
bishop moves to c2 for example will now
Ricky - and this pawn becomes very very
difficult to defend if I move like
Bishop t5 for example will now rook d4
let's say Bishop c6 simply rook d2 and
once again this pawn gets difficult to
to defend and if you really try to hold
on to this bishop with like Bishop f5
even King f6
now and we're getting quite creative but
we are getting this Bishop off the board
somehow so the whole point of this is by
pushing this a pawn down the board you
create threats on the Queen side you
create threats to trade off the a pawns
giving black this past pawn and by
trading pawns you get yourself a lot
closer to a drawn endgame where you're
willing to sacrifice the bishop for
White's final remaining pawns so this I
believe is how a niche giri should have
gone about trying to draw this game
active play playing with the rook
getting activity and looking to fight
back on the Queen side instead what we
got from a niche Gary was this series of
bishop moves that just kind of left me
unimpressed but should be one simply g4
they should see three rook d6 now Bishop
back to f6 trying to passively blockade
but against the rook it's not good
enough Bishop e6 comes on the board four
Maxima Shilla graph now simply rook c7
but the King starts to advance with King
e4 this Bishop drops back and now rook
d3 once again MVL going to avoid the
rook trade at all
you know crossroads here no reason to
take their works off the board
it makes blacks defense that much easier
now it's it's probably still not too
late for black to end up drawing this
game but you really do have to start
going for things like b5 now you have to
start playing on this Queen side instead
a niche Gary goes for King up six
hitting this Bishop Bishop back to b3
and now
b5 does come on the board it's it's it's
nice it's a nice idea but the black
pieces are in much worse position than
they were quite a few moves ago when I
was suggesting there was like a five and
a four
so now b5 MBL comes up at the moon 45
and this rookie or this trick is
attacking this pawn quite nicely rook c5
once again and BL not looking in to
trade rooks gets York d7 and we are
starting to see some of the problems for
black here it's tough to hold all of
these pieces together and in the
meantime keep a constant watchful eye on
the move g5 so for the moment everything
is together so black plays the move a5
now the move Rick a seven for MBL is
starting to threaten this pawn a4 but
now Bishop d5 and the king in the center
is totally safe from all checks
thanks to this bishop this ranked
defense is being interfered with so g5
might become threatening very very soon
and the black king is not totally safe
on f6 either checks could always come
and these Queen side pawns have actually
been quite weakened by this push rather
than becoming active rook c1 comes on
the board but now Rick a6 check came
back to g7 and King f5 and the end is is
kind of near for black if I'm a hundred
percent honest white has invaded quite
far with this King and g5 is going to
come on the board eventually or even
just simply f5 rook c7 was blacks try
trying to defend the seventh rank but
now Rick a5 rook back to c5 King e6
Bishop d8 hits the rook okay eighths
Bishop up to h4 and you're just kind of
passing the time now you're okay seven
isn't check King over to f8 and now
after your cage seven finally pawns
begin to fall and this is the problem
here with these extra ponds white is
able to slowly work his way up the board
with his pieces create threats around
the black King and that's how exactly
you should play when you have a rook and
a bishop against a rook and a bishop of
the other color you need to keep the
rooks on the board to create threats
against the opponent pieces and use that
to advance up the board and attack their
weaknesses and now this game is quite
simply dead lost for a niche Gary missed
this chance to get active to play on the
Queen side and now it's all over
so Bishop g3 was played in the game this
does allow f5 now and if you play a move
like Bishop f4 trying to hold on well
you're gonna get met with f6 and you
know checkmate checkmate
it hurts a little bit so can't be played
rook c7 instead now white picks up the
free pawn and connected pass pawns are
gonna be enough here
Anish well as our MDL is now happy
trade off the rooks because connected
passed pawns against bishops of opposite
colors are are in fact still a win so
Bishop c6 even picks up blacks remaining
pawn on the Queen side and here a nice
Giri just resigned this game okay so
this was another interesting game
endgame from Magnus Carlsen Invitational
once again and the points to take away
from this are when you end up in an
endgame with bishops of opposite colored
like this but rooks are on the board
it's not going to be the simple easy
draw they might have been led to believe
when you you know hear people talking
about bishops of opposite colors rooks
on the board allow you to make threats
against the enemy King allow you to make
threats against even the bishop itself
can become a target as well as threats
against the remaining pawns on the board
and it gives you a lot more flexibility
to work with your pieces and as MBL did
in this game the way to work with it is
to push your pieces up the board keep
threats against the enemy King and use
your extra past pawn to your advantage
as MVL did in this game okay I have just
one more endgame for you guys before we
get out of here this is of course the
end game between Fabiano Cara Juana and
ding leerin Fabi
I believe barely won the match against
ding there were some there was some
back-and-forth in this one and Fabi
ended up winning in Armageddon but this
is one of the games that Fabi ended up
winning once again this is the endgame
class what are we doing here there's too
many pieces on the board I'm so confused
get these pieces please start trading I
don't understand anything oh my gosh so
many pieces on the board so complicated
this isn't an endgame wait a second hold
on takes takes takes c5 takes f4 ok I
think we dedicate I'm calling this
finally an endgame and of course this is
an endgame originating from a royal
apes' Berlin so what is going on in this
position what do you guys think who has
the advantage objectively and who has
the advantage practically and is the
answer the same
both of those is the answer it's just a
draw tell me tell me what you think here
tell me what you think there are some
imbalances in the positions saying it's
a simple draw might be a little bit
misleading this is an endgame I'm
willing to call this an endgame there's
a few different definitions of what an
endgame is a very popular one is the end
game kind of starts when the kings start
being able to contribute to the position
when the Kings can get active themselves
and start playing without having to
worry quite as much about the threat of
checkmate
that's when the end game can kind of
begin no it's not a perfect definition
of course in a lot of major piece end
games the King still comes under fire
but it's it's one that kind of fits here
the Kings can start contributing
so yeah I like white here and the reason
I like white is in fact because of the
better minor piece as well as slightly
more active and rooks in this case now
if you ask a computer the computers
gonna say it's it's a dead draw and
probably it is with perfect play but
practically black is the one with more
problems to solve he does have a pretty
active Bishop on d4 but the fact is it's
locked on the same color as all these
pawns and this pawn on c7 in particular
may become a bit of a weakness that
black has to keep track of in the
meantime White has a similar weakness on
c2 but the difference is in this Bishop
can never attack that square so only
rooks are going to be able to hit this
weakness on c2 whereas the White Knight
could potentially get at the c7 pawn the
other advantage as I said is the
advantage in activity this rook is a
little bit more active than blacks
pieces and so black is perhaps a little
bit worse in terms of activity now there
are a couple things you can do here with
black the computer actually wants to
just play the move rook e8 but the
problem is of course white can now
really take off this H five pawns H five
pawns indefensible for example an
example line is King g7 Rick takes age
five king g6 rook age four and now Ricky
- and so white gives away the C pawn in
exchange for this aged pawn and with
this imbalance white once again might
have some more practical chances with
the past H pawn being so far off the
board but he's also going to have a lot
of weaknesses that he has to keep track
of as well on the Queen side so perhaps
that was best play in the game ding
Lauren very naturally it just plays the
move King h7 the idea being now you
can't really win this this age pawn
Fabia plays very simply as well you
simply bring the King in to play King g2
to f3 now this King is doing a great
defensive job from f3 stopping the rook
from invading on the e2 square it's a
great way to play against the rooks just
take away their invading squares
and it's also quite safe on f3 this pawn
guards these two checking squares these
two files are more or less going to stay
closed and so you can't really get at
this king especially with this F pawn
here that being said five comes on the
board black is trying to push this pawn
up the board make that King feel a
little bit less comfortable but perhaps
this move was a bit of a mistake
cuz now white can actually get the
advantage we're running out of time here
so I'm not gonna ask you guys to find it
the best move here for white is what was
played in the game simply ninety three
is highlighting that this pawn is a
little bit weak just a little bit weak
in the game Bishop g7 was played and now
if you play a move like Knight takes f5
the problem is Bishop e5 comes on the
board play move like rook takes f5 or it
takes c3 is an even simpler tactic so
you can't take this pawn just yet but
what you can do is the move that Fabiano
played in the game the very nice move
rook g1 now if black plays a little bit
nonchalantly here with something like
rookie 7 well the move rook g5 is going
to come and the rooks are really killing
together if you play move like King aged
six highlighting that Norrell trying to
play against this no Knight takes f5
comes with check lastly if you play move
like Bishop h6 trying to solve all your
problems
well now after work age four you can't
play King h6 and so the fact is
tactically black is just losing a pawn
here so that is the first part of this
endgame I wanted to look at does that
make sense to everybody so white has a
slight advantage in activity so black
has to be pretty careful here f5 was not
careful enough
and after some accurate play black or
white ends up winning this pawn by force
now this is the part of the endgame
that's gonna be kind of difficult to
replicate in your own games it just
involves calculating and seeing these
kinds of threats the second part of the
endgame I wanted to talk about is what
happens now after Bishop h6 or a cage
for and f4 is played how Fabi ends up
converting up the pond so right now h5
and c7 are both hanging rookie five
hangs onto the h5 pawn but Knight takes
c7 now
is the extra pawn for Faviana rook f6
comes on the board now and Fabi ends up
playing this move c3 so of course with
the extra pawn in order to really make
it felt in the position you need to
create a passed pawn and that's exactly
what Fabi is trying to do here so in the
game Rick g6 was played allowing rook d1
now Rick c6 is met with Knight b5 King
g6
and after d4 we end up with this passed
with this past pawn for Fabi however
things get a little bit more complicated
than that like a young young young
I'll tell take Yong Yong gustafson also
it's very difficult sentence to say so
after this some tricky tactics actually
come on the board perhaps Fabi ends up
in a little bit of trouble rook takes b5
is ding Lorenz choice a takes b5 and now
if black had found the move rook f6 it
would have been a really really
interesting game Bishop g5 is going to
be black's next move just simply picking
up this rook on h4 in exchange white
would get to push this pawn really far
up the board but this was unfortunately
missed in the game after rook to c3
check was played simply King e4 now
Bishop g5 rook g1 comes on the board
King age 6 and now rook takes f4 Bishop
takes that for king takes up 4 is played
so some complicated tactics there ended
up going ding Lorenz white until ding
Lauren missed the the nice idea of rook
f6 and this is the the last part of the
endgame I wanted to talk about here this
pure rook endgame so you can probably
see the result on your screen but this
one is more simple than the other end
games tonight how do you win this with
white and how do you try to draw with
black what do you think what do you
think what do you do to go for a draw
here with black and how do you
crush your opponents hopes of ever
drawing the position with whites
hello to chest bass Arabia thank you for
tuning in mm just waiting on the chat to
catch up see what they think
see what they think here so okay black
to move here black plate rook takes b3
sir I'll give you the position with with
white to move as well
so okay you guys kind of have have the
right idea here the way white wins this
game is using this deep on and so the
one kind of misstep I wanted you guys to
avoid was trying to go after more pawns
in the black camp trying to be fancy
playing moves like I don't know even
like rook g5 trying to just get this
rook even more active and take off some
more black pawns this is definitely not
the way to to win this this position now
Rick g5 might might not be the first
move that comes to mind for you guys but
I've seen this in a lot of games where
players with this extra past pawn
they'll get kind of caught up in in the
specifics of the position you know
they'll be afraid to give away their
other pawns when in fact in a position
like this the the easy winning idea is
to simply push the pawn to victory so
move like Rick g5 is really giving away
a lot because now if blacks smart black
will start pushing the a pawn and this
is really just going to end up in a draw
now for example if you play move like
Rick d5 really going after this pawn
blacks just gonna ignore you a3 directly
rook d6 is a check King g7 or takes p6
we can pick off this h3 pawn now if we
want and well you've been busy pushing
all these pawns well taking all these
pawns Black has pushed his relevant past
pawns and suddenly the game is a lot
more complex than he used to be and by
no means is this winning for white so
that's the misstep I wanted to talk
about in this end game it's the reason I
kind of wanted to show it is after a
move like York takes b3 you really just
don't want to get caught up in defending
your own pawns and going after more
pawns the key to winning this position
is to play moves like d5 you just push
the D pawn and then the black rook is
going to have to sacrifice itself and
the game is going to end now you might
have heard the saying rooks belong
behind passed pawns but rook d3 here
isn't going to be good enough and due to
the cut off King so Bobby would just
push in this manner so it takes b5 was
not played in the game actually a4 was
played in the game but now rook d1 and
is just going to be dead let me see this
pawn pushed directly to victory note
Bobby takes no time to deal with
anything else he just pushes this pawn
and after if d3 ding lauren ends up
resigning and that is the way to win
this endgame okay that is all I've had
for you guys tonight in the end game
class thank you very much for joining me
here once again for more games from the
magnus carlsen invitational tournament
going on right now if you're watching
live be sure to head over to our twitch
channel where we will actually be
continuing the fun with the analyzer
games class if you're watching the video
then this is it goodbye everyone thank
you so much for watching and I will see
you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you